la culture autochtone est au coeur de la
vie et de la cuisine de malines est
originaire de la nation watchou et n en
colombie britannique
elle est chef cuisinière installé à
montréal depuis près de dix ans elle a
sa propre entreprise de traiteur baptisé
chef malou son surnom d'enfance
elle sert des repas traditionnels dans
des événements et donne des cours de
cuisine autochtone mais depuis un an et
le moins de temps à consacrer à son
entreprise en janvier 2019 il ya plus
d'un an
des militants ou et souhaitait non
tentées pour une première fois
d'empêcher les travaux de construction
du pipeline courte orgas link quatorze
personnes avaient été arrêtés par la grc
ce mois là une manifestation s'est tenue
devant le bureau de justin trudeau à
montréal
[Musique]
il était là c'était le début de son
militantisme pour défendre les membres
de sa communauté
elle accuse justin trudeau de les avoir
laissés tomber
elle est d'ailleurs allé lui dire en
personne quelques semaines plus tard à
une assemblée publique à saint-hyacinthe
en faveur de project à deux chiffres
avec amauri serait le territoire dit
elle appartient au chef héréditaire
c'est avec eux que le premier ministre
doit négocier et pas le conseil de bande
le message de marc linéaire s'est rendu
jusqu'à joliette
le centre d'amitié autochtone de
lanaudière l'a invité pour un souper la
semaine dernière albine la soirée
c'était vraiment un soirée de
sensibilisation
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
le post m des dizaines de personnes y
ont assisté
depuis le centre fréquenté surtout par
des membres de la nation atikamekw
amassé près de 500 $ pour soutenir le
combat des chefs wet wet n je pense que
c'est important à travers le pays les
autochtones particulièrement veut
redonner au peuple son hôtel pour
qu'est-ce qu'ils font parce que je
travaille fort pour défendre les droits
autochtones de dreux d'environnement le
droit
territoriale et c'est important pour
nous de pouvoir contribuer à ça et cet
appui est visée bleus partout dans les
rues de montréal et sur les voies
ferrées les revendications des
manifestants dépasse la simple question
du pipeline quelle est la solution vous
croyez à cette crise qui paralyse le
réseau ferroviaire et naval le respect
du territoire et des traditions
autochtones
si cher hf malouf